[Applaudissements]
de la joie sur les visages de ces rubis
woman ce dimanche 8 janvier les
Panthères viennent de remporter leur
deuxième victoire de la saison face à
Courbevoie en régionale une belle
performance pour cette entente Evinoise
entreprise et Vélizy-Villacoublay en
rugby à 10 on concrétise du travail
qu'on fait depuis maintenant un an et
demi quoi parce que c'est depuis l'année
dernière la saison dernière qu'on a 7
ans avec Vélizy et là on est récompensé
de tous les efforts qu'on fait à chaque
entraînement dans le club de plaisir on
travaille depuis une dizaine d'années
sur la section féminine ici le rugby
féminin connaît un vrai boom avec une
soixantaine de licenciés trois fois plus
en trois ans aujourd'hui on a le bonheur
d'avoir des filles dans toutes les
catégories des moins de 8 des moins de
10 des moins de 12 des moins de 15 on
est le seul club à yvelinois avoir une
équipe complète en moins de 15 donc les
millimètres et nos canettes depuis 3 ans
performent énormément sur tout le
résultat à terme la section féminine a
pour objectif d'aller vers le haut
niveau dans les trois quatre prochaines
années mais le principal est de créer
avant tout une identité de club c'est ça
notre force qu'on a créé une famille on
fait plein de choses ensemble on essaie
de se voir après l'entraînement de se
voir les week-ends